if we consider the cell to be an factory
then mitochondria of the cell is
comparable to the power plant which
produces energy now mitochondria has two
different membranes the outer membrane
and the inner membrane the inner
membrane has invaginations known as
christie which really increases its
surface area and it has important
functional role inside these membrane
bound layers there is a mitochondrial
matrix now the matrix has mitochondrial
DNA and there are ribosomes as well
inside the matrix now mitochondrial
inner membrane is almost impermeable to
the ions and its composition is very
different from the outer membrane
mitochondrial inner membrane has
specific type of lipids known as cardio
ligh pins which has four fatty acid
chains now cardio Lapine's it's typical
for mitochondrial inner membrane it has
been thought that mitochondria was not
even present in the prokaryotic cell so
when the evolution happened the
ancestral prokaryotic cell undergo
membrane invagination and eventually
involved some aerobic bacterium like
alpha proteobacteria and as a result
what happened is the ancestor eukaryote
cell live in symbiosis with that
bacteria and throughout the course of
evolution
it became mitochondria now there are a
lot of evidence to believe this notion
because mitochondria and alpha
Proteobacteria has a lot common in terms
of their genetic sequences not only
genetic sequences when alpha bacterium
was engulfed by the primitive cell or
the primitive cell which was about to
evolve it really involved the
the Proteobacteria and wrapped around a
specific membrane that's why
mitochondria has two membranes one
membrane which is derived from the host
cell or host primitive Broker
prokaryotic cell and now its own
membrane which has previously not only
that these alpha proteobacteria believed
to have their own genetic material which
is very similar to mitochondrial genetic
material and it has its self-sustaining
system it has its own ribosomes and
protein producing machinery not only
that these alpha Proteobacteria has
their own mechanism to produce ATP's
soon they produced enough amount of ATP
and released it into the cytosol of the
cells now the cells which engulfed them
mitochondria are engulfed out of a
Proteobacteria had that advantage of
having energy coming from that organelle
and as an exchange they give them
nutrients that's how the symbols is
relation to place and that's the story
behind mitochondrial evolution in a
different video we would talk about it
much more details but let's talk about
other aspect now scientists really
tracked mitochondria in real time just
to understand its morphology and it
turns out mitochondrial morphology is
pretty dynamic from live cell when my
people when scientists track the
mitochondrial morphology they see with
time mitochondria really change their
dynamics and their morphology not only
that mitochondria can fuse together they
can good away from each other so fission
and fusion events are very common for my
mitochondrial physiology now alteration
in mitochondrial Christy or the membrane
diversion ation the membrane inner
membrane surface area is highly
associated with diseases and in separate
videos we would learn about more however
let's talk about a little bit about the
energy generation machinery because
after all mitochondria is the powerhouse
of the cell right so the inner membrane
of the mitochondria has the electron
transport chain imagine it to be a
transporter
of electron and as an exchange it pumps
out protons and these protons create a
proton motive force which is used by a
motor let's say the ATP synthase to
generate ATP now these two components
the ATP synthase and the transport chain
are very similar to a fuel combustion
unit in a power plant which combust the
fuel and a power generator unit which
generates the electricity so ATP
synthesis very close to a power
generator and definitely it's generate
the energy currency for the cell the ATP
right and we would learn about this
electron transport chain and ATP
synthase how it functions in a separate
video and the link is given at the end
of this video now mitochondria is hub
for multiple metabolic pathways one of
the most important one is the fatty acid
oxidation now fatty acid gets inside the
mitochondria and then beta oxidation of
fatty acid takes place and fatty acid
gets broken down into acetyl co n as I
ELQ away and it's broken down to acid
ELCA way till the end and that acetyl co
a which is a very important substance
could be used for several different
other metabolic processes now we got our
mitochondria from our mother who is so
because in the time of fertilization
when the sperm is fertilizing the ovum
what happens is the sperm heads touches
the ovum and it the pronucleus of the
male pronucleus with the ovum but the
tail falls off and the sperm tail has
the mitochondria as a result we only get
the mitochondria from one more mom the
mitochondria is important for several
metabolic pathways such as trip cycle
all the Krebs cycle
enzymes are present inside the
mitochondrial matrix and some are also
membrane bound
not only that the site trick acid which
is generated from the krebs cycle can be
channeled outside and from that citrate
mal mallet could be formed and that
could be used for fatty acid
biosynthesis pathway now the Saxon
succinate that is a part of the [ __ ]
cycle the succinate can be used to
produce sucks in air iike way and the
sucks in air along with glycine could be
the raw material for formation of him
very acid breakdown could also take
place in the mitochondria as we have
discussed and definitely a TV production
happens inside mitochondria so from this
slide we can clearly understand so many
metabolic processes are involving
mitochondria not only that urea cycle
takes place in mitochondria and goes on
hand on hand with a sigh trick acid
cycle all these evidences mix
mitochondria is such an important
organelle not for only generating energy
but also for metabolic and sugar
physiology now
mitochondria is important for Ross
generation like Ross means reactive
oxygen species now reactive oxygen
species are really harmful for the body
so mitochondrial malformation or
malfunction can lead to a lot of Ross
generation and harmful effect on the
body so mitochondrial physiology is
super important for a healthy organism
now mitochondria are super important for
the functioning of the brain the brain
cells use mitochondria more than any
other cells especially at the synapses
which are very happening region where a
lot of neurotransmitter release is
happening it turns out with activity
mitochondrial localizes to the synapses
and that gives the energy for this
dynamic processes which is going on in
the synapses several diseases like
Parkinson's disease is associated with
mitochondrial dysfunction
forget about Parkinson disease many
other diseases like Alzheimer's Perkins
and Huntington ALS all of these diseases
are associated with my toe patty or
mitochondrial dis
function or altered mitochondrial
function and all these all these
mitochondrial dysfunction is going on in
Iran via astrocytes etc so mitochondrial
function in neuron astrocytes and
microglia are super important for a
healthy physiology because when it goes
wrong it can lead to several
neurodegenerative diseases as shown here
not only that mitochondrial take parts
in apoptosis
that means programmed cell death when
the damage caused to a cell or damage
caused to a genome is irreparable then
there are damage sensors which
ultimately lead to transcription and
translation of pro-apoptotic gene such
as Beck's which creates holes in the
mitochondria and from this holes
cytochrome C which is a part of the
electron transport chain leaks out and
cytochrome C in the cytoplasm gives out
the signal or the message for the cell
to get destroyed by a programmed fashion
which is called apoptosis so
mitochondria is super important for so
many different physiological aspects and
energy generation so I hope you get an
overview of mitochondria from this video
in my other videos I would be talking in
several aspects of mitochondrial
dynamics and efficient and energy
generation via electron transport chain
so stay tuned if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to Like share and subscribe thank you
bye